good morning
my name is ryan roberts i'm an
oncologist caring for children with
cancer
and a scientist studying the biology of
sarcomas a nationwide children's
hospital
in columbus ohio i'm also a board member
of the canines and kids foundation which
is the organizer of this meeting
we'd like to welcome you to the 2020
pause for a cure symposium
this is the third iteration of this
meeting which is designed to foster
collaboration across
industry academia advocacy communities
and regulatory communities
to share the most current science
illustrating how alike
cancers shared by kids and dogs can be
the fact is that kid tumors are more
like dog tumors than they are like adult
tumors
and we hope to show how integrated
approaches can lead to true win-win
outcomes helping to crush cancer at both
ends of the leash
a phrase that happens to also be our
foundation's tagline
we invite you to learn more about
canines and kids mission by visiting our
virtual booth
in the exhibit hall where by the way you
can also get your own crush cancer face
mask if you're interested
we want to thank the partners and
sponsors that have made this event
possible
in a year of pandemonium and encourage
you to also visit their
virtual booths in the exhibit hall
these include merck who is our
co-presenter for the second year in a
row
the petco foundation in collaboration
with blue buffalo foundation
who are our title sponsors sanofi
our keynote sponsor the parker institute
for cancer immunotherapy
rally foundation for childhood cancer
research
elias animal health and morris animal
foundation
we point out that there are several
features of this virtual meeting that
you can use to take advantage
of opportunities to network and to talk
with other
participants these include the
networking lounge which will be
available between
meetings and even during meetings where
you can meet with speakers and other
participants
the chat function where you can talk to
individuals directly
and the poster session where you'll see
several presentations and videos from
fantastic submitted abstracts
when you log into each presentation or
panel
you'll have an opportunity to submit
questions via the ask
question box the speakers and moderators
will receive these questions in the
background
and be able to organize them to address
questions within the q a portion of each
presentation
any questions submitted and not
addressed within the session
will be followed up with an email
following the event
the presentations for the day will be
listed in chronological order within the
auditorium
and there will be a 15-minute countdown
before they start so that people can log
in and view the presentation content
before the broadcast begins
presentations will remain available to
all participants for on-demand viewing
for 12 months following this live event
to start this meeting off we'll be
privileged to hear a keynote address
highlighting the historical development
of this field
from the unique perspective of dr peter
adamson
dr adamson has made a career out of
advocating for
innovation and systematic improvement in
the care of children with childhood
cancer
first as a translational scientist at
chop
and then serving as chair of the
children's oncology group
he was appointed by president obama to
serve on the national cancer advisory
board
and was a member of the blue ribbon
panel for vice president biden's cancer
moonshot initiative
since completing his term as president
of cog he has transitioned into a role
as a leader within
industry currently serving as the global
head of oncology development
and peat end of pediatric innovation at
sanofi
i have long respected peter for his
vision and his ability to see how
academic
and industry efforts can align toward
common goal
to as we would say crush cancer
he's been a long-standing advocate for
integrated drug development
using approaches that benefit both
veterinary and human medical communities
i can't think of a better individual to
start us off today to give his
perspective
to that theme please join me in
welcoming
peter adamson
good afternoon it's a pleasure to be
here i want to thank the organizers of
what i'm sure will be a very important
and interesting symposium
for inviting me so let me share my
screen and get started with
today's talk
so today i'm going to give you an
overview of new drug development and
take a historical perspective
i'm going to talk about where we started
where we got stuck
and where we're going as far as
disclosures
i now am an employee of sanofi based in
cambridge mass
but i will not be discussing any of
sanofi's products
i do want to give a special thank you to
my colleagues richard gorlick
katie janeway and doug hawkins for
sharing their knowledge their
perspectives and
importantly many of their powerpoint
files i do want to emphasize however
that all
errors in this talk are mine alone
new drug development i'm going to talk
briefly about novel cytotoxics and then
talk
a little bit in more detail about
targeted therapy
i've broken targeted therapy down into
two broad buckets
one molecular oncology focusing
primarily on small molecules
and then more broadly on immuno oncology
so let me start with novel cytotoxics
and for that i'm going to give a very
brief history
of methotrexate adriamycin and platinum
map chemotherapy chemotherapy and
surgery
continue to be the cornerstone of
treatment for children adolescents and
adults with osteosarcoma
and understanding how we arrived at map
chemotherapy
i think begins to help understand some
of the challenges we have
so we have to go back to 1967 and isaac
gerasi who
was at my former institution children's
hospital philadelphia
began treating children with acute
lymphoblastic leukemia
with high-dose methotrexate shown on the
right here are some of the doses you use
they range from 500 milligram
per meter squared up to 1500 milligram
per meter squared
but to put it in perspective and again
this is 1967.
standard dose of methotrexate back then
was 2.5 or
5 milligrams so going to doses
of a gram with luca voron rescue was
quite a leap and really was based on a
good deal of pre-clinical
pre-clinical research as well as
understanding
the pharmacology of methotrexate
forward to norm jaffe looking at the
data and then in 1972
reporting on 10 patients he treated with
high dose methotrexate and osteosarcoma
and reported both partial responses and
complete responses
to high-dose methotrexate with
leukovorum rescue
and that really set the stage for
multi-drug chemotherapy
and by the 1980s multi-drug chemotherapy
was beginning to establish itself in the
treatment of patients with osteosarcoma
but it became controversial and the
controversy was
not everyone was convinced that
chemotherapy was responsible
for the observed improvements and
outcome and thus
michael link working with investigators
including theresa villetti the
former chair of the original pediatric
oncology group or pog
set out to do a randomized trial
and that randomized trial was going to
ask is chemotherapy
truly important for taking care of
patients with osteosarcoma
and the results were rather conclusive
now shown on the right
are the survival curves with the upper
curves being
patients who were treated with adjuvant
chemotherapy there were two groups of
patients because
it was becoming clear in many in the
eyes of many investigators
that chemotherapy was important and not
everyone was willing to be randomized so
the study looked at both randomized
patients and those are the curves with
fewer patients as well as those patients
that selected
to be on chemotherapy and those are the
curves with more patients
nonetheless it clearly demonstrated a
significant advantage
to adjuvant chemotherapy and by 1986
established that adjuvant chemotherapy
was an important component of treatment
for patients with osteosarcoma
well this curve is also important
because it really shows what our
challenge has been
so if one looks at this curve from a
paper in 1986 from michael link
and compares it to a curve from data 30
years later
you can see we haven't made progress
these
curves are virtually overlappable
we are stuck at about 70
of entry survival for patients with
localized osteosarcoma so
let's take a step back and talk about
how we have made progress in the
treatment of childhood cancer
and really the it's been the application
of some generalizable treatment
principles
that have driven this i want to share
with you what i think are the four
fundamental principles that have helped
improve the outcome for children with
cancer
the first is combination regimens that
is a concurrent administration of
multiple non-cross-resistant anti-cancer
drugs
that became the cornerstone combination
chemotherapy
of cancer treatment not only in children
but cancer treatment in adults with
cancer
dose intensity administer the highest
tolerable dose at the shortest tolerable
interval
now this was most recently realized in a
study in patients with ewing sarcoma
with interval compressed chemotherapy
another
another approach to dose-intensive
chemotherapy
adjuvant setting administration of drug
when disease burden is minimal
and risk-adapted treatment by using
biologic and other risk factors and
perhaps most importantly
the response to initial therapy guiding
further therapy
these treatment principles have driven
the improvement and outcome for children
with cancer
and this is probably best visualized
when one looks at the history of
children with acute lymphoblastic
leukemia
so shown here is data from the
children's cancer group children's
oncology group
from the late 60s to most recently up to
2009
and beyond the quantum leap that
occurred in the early 1970s
with the advent of preventive cns
therapy for all children with all every
generation of trials has improved the
outcome
and it's improved the outcome in large
measure by applying
these principles however the story for
osteosarcoma
is quite different even though these
principles would have been applied
over the years progress hasn't been
realized
so when look when one looks at the u.s
really since
the 1980s there's been no progress being
in children less than 15 years old or 15
to 19 years
of age you've seen no progress this is
not just the u.s phenomenon
looking at the curve on the right from
mike isaac's paper
again whichever cooperative group group
has looked
we always end up at the same place we
have
not made advances by applying these
principles
this was i think most clearly
demonstrated
in the largest trial in patients with
osteosarcoma
and that was uranus one
collaborative study between uh europe
and america
that looked at whether whether in
addition to
map chemotherapy the addition of
iphosphide and etobicide
in a subset of patients could improve
the outcome so it was a large randomized
trial
and they applied these principles the
first principle was
adapting therapy based on initial
response
so for patients who were poor responders
to initial two cycles of chemotherapy
they were randomized to receive either
continued map chemotherapy
or map chemotherapy with the addition of
cycles of ie vp69 phosphamide or ia
iphosphamide and adriamycin now
recognize
that vp16 and nyphosphamide both had
single agent activity and as a
combination
at upwards response rates of 40 to
almost 50 percent
in relapsed and refractory patients so
there
was likely not a more effective regimen
that was potentially non-cross-resistant
to map
and that's what went forward
unfortunately you're all familiar with
with the results overlapping curves this
did not improve the outcome
it checked every box combination
regimens dose intensity adjuvant
treatment
risk adapted therapy but
unfortunately uramus one is not an
outlier even as we try to identify
novel agents in the relapse from
refractory setting
the vast majority of our cytotoxic
studies have not
shown positive results one can go from
drugs like topotecan and oxalic platinum
all the way up to most recently
arribulin we are not seeing signals of
efficacy
so fast forward i think we've all come
to the conclusion
that for novel cytotoxics no meaningful
likelihood of improving
the outcome will emerge and would have
to be under rather exceptional
circumstances
that we would continue to develop new
studies for such agents
so let's turn to targeted therapy and
i'm going to begin with
molecular oncology well
step one in any targeted therapy
including osteosarcoma
is identify the target now for most
childhood cancers
we have a different kind of problem if
one looks at the mutational landscape of
cancer
and shown here are the somatic mutation
frequencies by the different types of
cancers
on the left side of this curve with very
low
mutation frequencies are many childhood
cancers
on the right side of the curve you have
tumors like melanoma
lung lung squamous cell carcinoma orders
of magnitude higher
the outlier for us in pediatric oncology
is osteosarcoma so if one looks at
the circus plot of a patient with
osteosarcoma
the genome is remarkably disrupted
no other pediatric cancer has a genome
as disrupted
as osteosarcoma what's driving this
well we learned about 10 years ago of
something that's now called
chromothrypsis this was a paper by
stevens and colleagues
massive genomic rearrangement acquired
in a single catastrophic event during
cancer development so they uncovered
this
where there where there are tens to
hundreds of genomic rearrangements that
occur
in a one-off cellular crisis and when
one
looks across the spectrum of cancers
looking at the percentage of samples
with chromosomes
at the highest end or the red arrow the
second highest
is osteosarcoma so this leads the way
in disrupted genomes
what does that mean for identifying
targets
well i think the simplest way of putting
it
is it means it's complicated
and the reason it's complicated is
because there are so many
different variations however
progress is being made so this is work
that was driven in large measure by a
parent advocate that teresa beach
working with a number of investigators
in
foundation medicine and basically
started to find
small subsets of recurrent potential
targets
and this has helped setting the stage
now for clinical trials
one of the largest clinical trials
taking place
to look for signals of targeted agents
is the nci children's oncology group
pediatric match
studies where specific genomic testing
is done
looking for a portfolio of different
potential targets
if the target is found a drug can be
administered in a phase two setting
so shown here in a study that's led by
will parsons and nepho sybils
the 10 current arms that are enrolling
and patients with osteosarcoma
are also participating in this study
this is not
the only study that's occurring with
targeted therapy we're seeing an
increasing number of targeted agents
being interrogated to see if there's a
signal
but perhaps one of the strongest signals
that has emerged in these patients
has been with multi-targeted kinase
inhibitors
so in this case these are agents that
don't just hit
one kinase but actually hit a number of
different kinases
and that's in fact what might be needed
in a disease that has heterogeneous as
osteosarcoma
but we are seeing repetitive uh
reports of reasonable partial response
rates and
perhaps even more importantly four-month
progression-free survival rates
that are telling us there's a signal
here that should be interrogated
so currently the children's oncology
group is developing a study
to look at map chemotherapy in
combination with cabazan
nib one of the multi-targeted tkis to
see if in fact
one it can be successfully combined and
two can we begin to see evidence
of an improvement in outcome
so where i would say we are um in
molecular oncology is normal
methodologies newer genomic testing is
beginning to be applied
and a number of leads are being
identified
and being pursued in the clinic so let
me now turn to immuno oncology
and you would think by my listing it
here as the last topic
it's the newest field of drug
development
and in some respects that that's true
in osteosarcoma that actually
is not true so
bear with me as i once again take you on
a on a very brief history
of immunotherapy for osteosarcoma
it begins with a surgeon pictured here
this is uh william coley william b coley
who was at the time called a bone
surgeon that would be called an
orthopedic surgeon
and in 1893 he published
this paper in the american journal of
medical sciences
entitlement the treatment of malignant
neoplasms by repeated inoculations of a
bacterial infection
and he reported ten cases he referenced
an early paper
and i think it's interesting to read the
case report from the publication
he made in 1891
so now 130 years ago
the treatment has become known as
coley's toxin
here's one of the cases in the cases
which i've collected there's one which
bears upon this question
the patient a male 35 years was operated
on by dr
bull in 1888 for a large
periosteal round cell sarcoma of the
lower third of the femur
with secondary deposits in the center of
the bone amputation in mid thigh and
upper thirds was performed
second week after operation the patient
had a very severe tech
attack of poemia multiple abscesses in
various parts of the body
fever 104 105.
last paragraph the patient has had no
recurrence and is now living nearly
three years after the operation but dr
coley
appropriately appeared cautious even
back in
the 1890s of course this is not
to be regarded as absolute evidence that
the attack of paemia had any influence
in preventing a recurrence
but when we consider the highly
malignant nature of the tumor
and remember how few do not recur there
still remains a reasonable degree of
probability
that such influence existed and he
pursued the idea of
generating a robust immune response
through infection
with high fevers by actually infecting
patients
with toxins that he knew would drive
fever to treat
patients with cancer including
predominantly patients
with sarcoma now this was met
with a fair amount of skepticism over
the years
but largely was then put on the back
burner completely
with the advent of radiotherapy and
ultimately
nitrogen mustard and other
chemotherapeutic
agents and that's where immunosur
immunotherapy remained up until
again probably the 1960s when it comes
to osteosarcoma
so this was a report of a vaccine trial
by
ralph markov and colleagues began in
1963
and they made a lyophilized homogenous
vaccine from the primary tumor tissue
and was given to a child with
osteosarcoma and pulmonary meds
and ultimately reported on that series
and the analysis they did suggested that
there may
be some benefit again an uncontrolled
single arm study
but the idea of vaccinating against the
tumor
developing immune response was being
pursued
pretty actively in the 1960s
now what i would say a a rather more
dramatic approach to this
uh was predominantly late 60s 1970s
adoptive immunotherapy a term that
really we would not see again probably
for
another decade in the treatment of
primary osteosocial
sarcoma and i've highlighted it on the
left
fresh aliquots of osteosarcoma obtained
at the time of surgical ablation
were transplanted to a human recipient
let me pause there they don't detail
exactly who this recipient was but it
was allogeneic
and actually you can dig back in the
literature and they
it appears we're predominantly
transplanting the tissue
into another patient with disseminated
osteosarcoma
i think um in the current era
many irbs would probably collapse when
they
heard this but this was done back in the
late 60s and 70s they would transplant
tissue
to a recipient reading on after periods
ranging from 14 to 21 days
the implants were excised and
presumptively sarcoma sensitized
peripheral blood mononuclear cells were
obtained from the recipient
by leukopheresis these allogeneic cells
were immediately infused into the
implant donor
adoptive immunotherapy late 60s early
70s
they reported on
i believe a total of 32 patients
they could not find clear evidence of an
anti-cancer effect
in this series now let's fast forward to
some more
recent signals uh for osteosarcoma
immunotherapy and muramil tripeptide
mtppe
pact had its own controversy but again
i don't think any of us would argue that
there was clear
signal that the immune system could be
engaged
more recently work done by nikki mason
at upenn
with a her2 tarting listeria trying to
induce
her2 specific immunity this in a canine
model
very intriguing data as well so some
clear signs
that the immune system could potentially
be engaged or can potentially be engaged
to treat patients with osteosarcoma
now immunotherapy really took off in the
last 15 years and one of the major
drivers
of that was the development of
checkpoint inhibitors the paper
i think one of the most seminal papers
was that
from jim allison's lab back in 1995
where he described ctla for and
and demonstrated that inhibitory signals
derived from ctla4 in an important way
that cancers evaded the immune system
and he continued to build on this work
and ultimately this hypothesis was
tested in patients with
melanoma with ibulimumab a ctla4
antibody
and this paper published in august of
2010 in the new england journal of
medicine
clearly showed a significantly improved
survival
of patients treated with ipolimab they
also
co-administered with gp 100 which didn't
seem to have an
impact uh beyond ipoloma map improved
the outcome
for patients with melanoma and this
launched
a real tidal wave of clinical trials
using checkpoint inhibitors
jim allison and tatsuku hanjo went on to
receive the 28 nobel prize in physiology
or medicine
for their work in this field and it
truly has transformed
not only how we think about cancer but
now today
how we treat cancer so
those of us in pediatric oncology when
these data emerged
most of us immediately started thinking
about osteosarcoma
because what soon followed was the the
the idea that it was a high burden of
antigens and
perhaps more importantly neo antigens
that would drive the response
to checkpoint inhibitors and where
would you look for the most neo-antigens
well you would look
in a tumor that had a highly disrupted
genome
and thus we thought osteosarcoma
if any tumor in pediatrics is going to
be responsive
it ought to be osteosarcoma well
unfortunately
like before it's complicated
so pembroluzumab a pd-1 inhibitor
shown on the left is a waterfall plot
and as you can see
in this study in the purple bars 19
patients with osteosarcoma only one
patient
with a response very very limited
activity
pembrolizumab but it hasn't been only
pembrolizumab a number of uh pd1 uh
inhibitors and pdl one inhibitors have
been studied
on the right a swimmer's plot for a
navalium map and if you look at the
second from bottom the swimmer's
plotting yellow
these are the patients with osteosarcoma
13 patients
you can see very quickly they stayed on
therapy for a maximum
of two cycles and the majority came off
before then
so highly disappointing that we could
not
leverage a major advance in cancer
treatment
for patients with osteosarcoma but
we and many people who do research in
this area
are learning more and we're learning
more understanding
what is driving the lack of
responsiveness and potentially
how to overcome that lack of
responsiveness
so this paper by dr wu at
md anderson immunogenomic landscape of
osteosarcoma
really uncovered some data and they drew
i'd say
five major conclusions from their work
mutation burdens are not associated with
immune infiltrate levels
so it's obviously the the t cells within
the tumor that are going to drive that
response
but they could not find that uh
correlation
uh surprisingly a low level of predicted
neoantigen expression and if you look
at the figure on the right looking at
the number of non-synonymous
mutations you can see the expressed neo
antigens
level in red are a very small minority
of what one would have hoped was being
expressed
they also went on to postulate and show
data suggesting low t
cell receptor productivity clonality
insufficient
immune infantry and ultimately evidence
for multiple
immunomodulatory mechanisms
this work and work by many other
investigators are now giving us
new clues and thinking about new and new
approaches
to immuno-oncology for patients with
osteosarcoma
and many of us really view this as an
exciting time
because uh the armamentarium that we now
have
in immuno oncology is continuing to grow
and grow almost at a daily basis
it's not just monoclonal antibodies that
are now available to us
an increasing number of antibody drug
conjugates
antibodies against targets that may be
quite relevant to subsets of patients
with osteosarcoma
are in the clinic we see by specific
antibodies being developed for solid
tumors tri-specific antibodies being
developed
really remarkable uh chemistry that is
undergoing to the development
of very potent and very specific
antibodies that can engage the immune
systems in ways that we really couldn't
have imagined 10 years ago
layer on that the advances in cellular
therapies
not only car t and building t cells
but now nk cells are coming onto the
horizon
so an increasing spectrum of approaches
that will hopefully begin to unravel
the recalcitrant nature of osteosarcoma
so despite dr coley having introduced
immunotherapy more than 130 years ago i
think it's best to think about immuno
oncology
as we really are just getting started
we're at the beginning of this process
can't come too soon but advances indeed
will come and i think in targeted
therapy and specifically in
immuno-oncology
we're going to see those advances come
for subsets of patients with
osteosarcoma
over the next five years so
let me close with another person
that was highly important to
improving the treatment for children
with cancer and specifically to
increasing the cure rate
for many treatment and many children
with cancer and that's true to yelling
and if you don't know uh dr ellion uh
work that she began in the 1940s and
continued through the 50s
60s and onward her laboratory developed
six more capital purine six diaguanine
azathioprine acyclovir
and even azt used for the treatment
of hiv truly a remarkable scientist
who was developing therapy
that today we would call targeted
therapy
back then the term hadn't been invented
but she knew exactly
what she wanted to go after in the cell
and to develop molecules to go after
that
and so she when she gave the
presidential address in
1985 to acr and two years later i think
she and george hitchens won the nobel
prize in medicine and physiology
this is what she said in the talk that
she entitled selectivity
ketochem of chemotherapy
for many years chemotherapists have
thought the touchstone
which would turn lead into gold the
magic bullet of erlick which would go
directly to the target
without harming normal normal cells and
she went on to say
once you find the basic biochemical
differences between the target and the
host
then seek ways to utilize this
information
those principles most certainly continue
to apply today
they apply for targeted therapies be it
molecular oncology or immuno oncology
so with that i'm going to end my talk
um my dogs roscoe and luna have been
waiting
patiently for me to stop talking to the
computer and i thank you
for your attention
good afternoon i'm dr joshua schiffman
and i'm here to tell you a little bit
about
childhood cancer dogs
and my life when i was 15 years old
i was actually diagnosed with a
childhood cancer called hodgkin lymphoma
as you can imagine and as would be the
case in any young teenager
this changed my life trajectory
completely
i said to myself self when i grow up
i want to become a pediatric cancer
doctor and take care of other kids with
cancer
just the way the doctors had taken care
of me
well life was good life was hard went to
undergrad medical school residency
and began my fellowship i finally
had arrived i was going to become a
pediatric
cancer doctor well just about that same
time
my wife and i decided we would get a dog
actually not these dogs behind me now
but a different dog a bernese mountain
dog
and we loved our dog this was bk for
four kids
and we called our dog roadie that was
his name
we were both from rhode island
originally well rhodey became a really
big part of our family
we ended up having kids as well and
about six years into rhodey's life
he began to limp and that was a problem
it turns out rhodey as a bernese
mountain dog
was diagnosed with something called
histiocytic sarcoma
a very very aggressive kind of tumor
that bernese mountain dogs tend to be
prone to
well it turns out along my own career
taking care of kids with cancer i became
very interested
in hereditary cancer and the genetics of
which kids get cancer and why including
myself when i was just 15 years old
and so unfortunately
we had to put rhodey to sleep and in the
process this
opened my eyes to the world of dogs and
cancer
and i met many many wonderful colleagues
and friends
like dr matthew green and dr amy
leblanc among many many others
who were able to teach me that it's not
just
kids that get cancer like my own
patients
but it's also dogs dogs get a tremendous
amount of cancer
and as you all know because you're
sitting there today watching
dog cancer and childhood cancer
is very very similar and in fact after
my own dog passed away from cancer
we began to focus in the lab and try to
understand
what are the genetics of dog tumors not
only which
kids would be getting cancer but what
dogs would be getting cancer
and how do they overlap and how can one
teach
the other how do we learn from dogs to
help kids with cancer
how do we learn from kids to help dogs
with cancer
and so along this adventure of trying to
study cancer in dogs of course we
got our own new dogs
we began to really think about not only
who's getting
more cancer like dogs and some of these
patients but even
who's getting possibly less cancer
this led to many other adventures
including elephants and
many other wild animal species and
eventually we even started
a biotech company to make new drugs
from nature and to take those drugs and
to learn from those drugs
about how to make new medicine not just
for kids with cancer
but for dogs with cancer and so it's
really come full circle for me
now working with this new biotech
company
trying to make cancer drugs called peel
therapeutics peel is the
hebrew word for elephant and trying to
take our new medicines
and see where do they fit taking care of
dogs with cancer and children with
cancer
and so my career really my whole life
has been focused on cancer
and animals and animals with cancer and
animals with more cancer
and animals with less cancer and it all
comes back
to canines and kids and pause
for the cure and it's really such an
honor to be able to have shared my
message with you today
and to tell you a little bit about my
own experiences
and why it is just so important to study
these animals to love them to cherish
them
and to learn from them so that we can
help other dogs
with cancer in the future and we can
help our patients
our children who have cancer as well
and they really go hand in hand both
ends of the leash
and again it's such a wonderful thing to
know that so many people
are interested in this area of research
and together
with our dogs and our human patients
we're going to make a difference in the
fight against cancer
so enjoy the rest of the conference and
again welcome
and thank you for allowing me to speak
to you today
hi thank you all for allowing me to join
you today and tell the story about
participating in a clinical trial as a
canine
parent i'm going to talk about our dog
once i anticipate in the trial and what
our experience was like
so first of all a little bit about cash
cash was a retired racing greyhound his
racing name was cg's mr cash
and he ran in 74 races finishing in the
top three
in 50 of those he was a healthy and
strong dog when he was diagnosed with
osteosarcoma
and as you can see from his photos he
was
a goofball
the timeline for cash's um
story with osteosarcoma is that he
started limping in early september of
2016.
the preliminary diagnosis came back from
an x-ray
and we presented him as a candidate for
the
national cancer institute and morris
animal foundation
cocci 22 clinical trial in late
september
he was presented at the university of
missouri colombia which we
affectionately call mizzou
here in missouri the diagnosis
of osteosarcoma in the left distal
radius was confirmed
on that day and his leg was amputated
the next day
three days later cash came home for
recovery and
he was par uh selected to participate in
the standard of care arm of that
clinical trial
so in in addition to the amputation he
received four doses
of carbo platinum chemotherapy and then
had to go back every eight weeks for
checkups
so the o word i'm not going to spend a
lot of time talking about osteosarcoma
because i know you are familiar with it
but just like in humans in canines it is
just as bad
it's painful and aggressive and even
with amputation
and chemotherapy the average lifespan is
only about 12 months
so why did we say yes well first of all
we wanted to eliminate the pain and
originally we had said no
but the trick with saying no is trying
to figure out
when to say goodbye before the leg
breaks
so by saying yes we were able to remove
the pain from cash
and then when we learned that childhood
osteosarcoma
is very similar to canine osteosarcoma
and that this clinical trial would be
looking for
additional medicines to extend life we
felt like that was the bonus reason to
get cash involved
my husband and i are both supporters of
science and we had the
capability and the flexibility to be
able to participate in the trial
so what do i mean by the capability and
flexibility
well the clinical trial experience
can be burdensome it was not burdensome
for us
because we had the flexibility to be
able to participate we had supportive
employers we were able to work from home
we were able to have a flexible schedule
and we were able to do the travel so
that's something that's very important
to consider
because there are specific protocols
that must be followed and if
those then you risk putting the trial in
our experience at mizzou was wonderful
we had great patient
and parent care there and really
everybody there became
like friends to us the doctors we became
very close to
and mostly we were in awe at just how
much of a difference that our dog could
make
to the science of curing this horrible
cancer
so there from in the end it turns out
that cash was one of the zoo's longest
survivors he was in remission for nearly
three years
and he touched many lives while he was
alive and i'd like to think that he's
still touching people's lives today
with the science that was built in that
clinical trial
so as a canine mom who has lost
a dog to cancer and as a person who
lives with a chronic
form of cancer i can really say this
with all sincerity
let's crush cancer at both ends of the
leash
thank you so much for giving me the time
to speak today
well thank you so much for this
opportunity to talk about the golden
retriever lifetime study
supported by morris animal foundation
and others i'm dr
rod page and i'm joined today by dr
janet patterson payne who
is the chief scientific officer for the
morris animal foundation
uh she'll be uh i'll be passing off the
conversation to her in uh 15 slides
so we're really pleased to be able to
provide this information and thanks to
the organizing committee for
pause for uh cure to allow us to uh to
present this we have a tremendous amount
of really fascinating data
to go through so i'm going to move right
on to
some of the the next slides so we
started thinking about what could
potentially be
a game changer for cancer prevention and
understanding a variety of other uh
outcomes from
a large population a lifetime cohort
essentially a cradle to grave uh sort of
a story from
a group of dogs that would help us to
understand the risk factors for
uh cancer so we began uh this
about um thinking about this almost uh
10 or 12 years ago and we
realized that we created something here
that has a tremendous
additional ancillary outcome
opportunity so study outcomes are going
to be
focused as you'll see in a moment on
some of the primary outcomes but
in addition we know that this is going
to
create a database so far you know five
million data points
on a population of dogs as they age and
as they go through their lifestyle to
look at
informing the health of dogs and other
species hopefully including humans
about some of the shared exposure
types of issues as well as helping to
be more of a policy type uh opportunity
for
looking at global healthcare and
companion animals
so um i think you'll i think you'll
really appreciate the
progress that we've made in the last 10
years in terms of a variety of different
technologies and a variety of different
opportunities to take advantage of this
and we built this for the for the
community
to be able to use this is an
observational study we don't interfere
with the
decisions that are made between a
veterinarian the owner and the dog
but we do collect information that can
be used to answer
any particular question of relevance
we began thinking about this um in terms
of what would it take in order to
determine the true incidence of cancers
the uh
some four of the most common cancers in
golden retrievers
and by so doing we came up with the
number of 3000 that would allow us to
be certain of reaching a an aggregate
aggregate endpoint over a 10-year period
of time
and by that period of time we'd be able
to put some very tight
uh confidence intervals around the true
incidents in a captive population which
has not been done before
we also want to go to make sure that we
provided a
diversity of geographic um
experiences and exposures as well as a
combination of
uh dogs in different gender uh status
categories
so that we could also begin to look at
systematic evidence about what happens
to
various disease outcomes as a function
of reproductive hormone status
so our observational phases has was
launched
in about 2000 2012 and
i'll go through some of the some of the
specifics of that but we were able to
enroll
three thousand dogs in about three years
and for
um the aggregate diagnosis we will set a
time point
of 500 aggregate
diagnoses in those four categories
lymphoma osteomast cell tumor high grade
mass cell tumor hemangiosarcoma
and once we reach that we know that the
dogs will know it will
still be why some of the dogs will be
alive and we will continue to monitor
them
again these are the four primary cancers
and we chose these
based on the nature of the impact that
the cancer burden has in golden
retrievers
from a study that was produced by the
golden retriever club of america back in
1998-99
and indicated that about 80 percent of
dogs that succumb to cancer
will die from these particular types of
tumors
and that about 50 to 60 percent of
golden retrievers purebred golden
retrievers will
die from cancer but we also realize that
we were
missing an opportunity if we didn't
include secondary endpoints
and we took from that same study uh a
series of
conditions and diseases that rose above
a four percent
uh greater incidence or prevalence for
that population so hypothyroidism
allergic diseases heart failure epilepsy
hip dysplasia and real failure
were the ones that came out of that
particular study as being
particularly common or common enough
but we pay attention to any other
condition that seems to be arising
at might rise above that level and we'll
continue to devote more resources to
that should that happen
so uh we we uh hit our
goal in 2015
and you can see uh from the map on the
left hand side of the slide that it's a
it's a dispersed um
enrollment pattern although it is
clear that also is associated with uh
you know
human population density as you would
expect and we have dogs that are
enrolled in
in all of the 48 states of the united
states with a distribution of
predominant
uh suburban uh environments but
rural and some urban environments so if
you look at
you know 10 or 3000 we have 300 dogs
that live
in a classified urban environment that
we can
look at some of the specific risk
factors that might be unique
for other outcomes
we go through a very large
effort to collect information on each
one of these dogs
and it is a it's a fairly uh sizeable
commitment from owners veterinarians
and a uh and a group of participants
that help
to manage the uh the group the cohort
so physical exams are done every year or
more frequently if needed
we also collect a whole series of
biological samples that are submitted to
a uh a formal
biorepository organization
questionnaires about the lifestyle diet
behavior are
completed by owners and a physical
examination essentially a very short
but important electronic medical record
questionnaire is made each year by
veterinarians that see these dogs
we also collect tumor and normal tissue
samples
at the time that a dog does develop
cancer for
purposes of looking at a variety of the
uh the basic
uh types of biological molecular genetic
changes that might occur
in in dogs with disease
so just for um uh sort of gee whiz sort
of factors here we've got
an example of the owner questionnaire
each one of those little
colored areas is a separate page
although this is
web-based and for any
particular owner they will be able to
pretty much go through and have a
variety of different
pages that they need to fill in but as
well they will
skip a number of areas that are not
relevant to that particular dog
so as owners are becoming more and more
familiar with the study uh it takes less
time for them to do this at the
beginning it was
um necessary to help uh support them
through it because it is kind of a
it's a fairly significant amount of
information but you'll
see that we with the help of a number of
um
individuals that are that were involved
with um
task force development that we were able
to put together
a very long list of things that could
potentially have an impact
on outcomes and including a
behavioral questionnaire that was
developed by james cerpel at the
university of pennsylvania
uh this is the veterinary questionnaire
that relates to physical exam
findings history and a dermal mass map
that is an automated uh process where
the veterinarian can
keep track of dermal lesions or dermal
masses
over time with both size and uh
and diagnosis
so moving right into where we are now uh
i'd like to
just sort of start by letting you know
that as of
um june 15th we had about 100
dogs that have withdrawn should be 2
720 and about 221 dogs that have
deceased
and the withdrawals are usual for
a study like this but in fact our
overall compliance rate is in the high
80s
80 which is quite good and withdrawals
are
very explainable so you'll see that um
we currently have only 221 dogs that
have died out of a cohort of 3 000
and i'd like to just remind you that
if you do the math that's really only
about that's less than
10 of the dogs that have
been eliminated from the cohort for
which there will not be any other
uh data points so even though we're now
six or seven
or even eight years into the study uh
we only have um 10 of the dogs that have
been
exited from uh data collection
not including the withdrawn dogs so
that's uh there's a lot of data
that will be flowing into the study over
the next uh six to eight years
uh so much so that it can be
overwhelming to think about
uh we are currently keeping track of
the different types of cancers that are
causing both that been identified and
those that have been
associated with with deaths um
so of the 221 total deaths
that 82 are from other diseases but
this is about 60 of the dogs that have
died of some sort of cancer uh lymphoma
high grade mast cell tumors demands
and other all other cancers so that
is very consistent with um some of the
other
larger non-prospective
or non-longitudinal studies but remember
this is a fairly
still a fairly young population of dogs
all of these dogs
are in the middle ages
middle of their age and a lot of the
lymphomas that we saw actually occurred
at a relatively young age the frequency
of diagnosis for
hemangiosarcomas is picking up quite
quickly
uh this is a bar graph of
not only the four primary tumors but of
the
other types of cancers that we've seen
um in some detail
we are uh close to having a enough
histiocytic sarcomas
to identify them as a primary endpoint
and may
choose to do that as this develops
but you know high grade soft tissue
sarcomas and all these other
tumor types are also
relatively interesting to follow over
time
in terms of the types of lymphomas that
are being reported
this pretty much identifies the pattern
that we would
likely expect and there'll be some
interesting
news from janet about how to how we're
going to
continue to phenotype these types of
lymphomas
at the beginning we had a challenge
identifying phenotypes for a variety of
reasons but
um things are moving along we had
predicted we'd see approximately
around 120 dogs of lymphoma so
all of this is is estimated from data
that
only exists in one particular area one
particular type so we are
kind of uh walking through and creating
our
creating this information as we speak
so um i'd like to pass the uh the
pointer over to
uh dr patterson kane and she can take it
from here about some of the
really incredible resources that are
available
thank you rod so i'm gonna go over
what's happening this year
in august this year we celebrated the
eighth anniversary of this study
which is an amazing achievement for
everybody involved
i'm going to go through the things
listed here i just wanted to say
i'll talk about our current partners at
the end
but we are currently establishing some
really exciting new partnerships
that will be announced before the end of
the year for those of you who
are in the private sector and might be
interested in becoming
involved with the study if you think you
can add some scientific value
you are very welcome to email me the
address is at the bottom there
or contact me via linkedin we'd be very
pleased to talk to you
so starting off with our initiative
around lymphoma
those of you involved in the veterinary
oncology field
would be very aware that when a dog gets
lymphoma
although it is optimal to have a tissue
biopsy specimen taken
it's not absolutely necessary in many
cases so we found that we
were not receiving samples from many of
the lymphoma
dogs that were going through these study
bits we therefore teamed up with dr anne
avery
of the hematopathology lab
at colorado state university just put a
face to the name that's dr avery there
and holding the golden retriever is
julia labadie
who is now the study epidemiologist
for the foundation has come to join us
so now we cover an aspirate being sent
to dr avery's lab
that gets typed examined by flow
cytometry
that means that ann can also isolate the
dna
for us obviously typing these as
t or b cell lymphomas is very important
for researchers who may wish to work
with us
uh dr avery's lab have actually
phenotypes
approximately 40 000 lympho
proliferative diseases from canine
patients
so that's been very positive and we've
had basically 100
uptake since then
and i just wanted to talk about the
biorepository
obviously if we're sampling 3 000 dogs
or close to
every year we have a lot of samples this
is not a picture of
our biorepository but just so you can
visualize it in your mind our samples
probably fill about nine of these
minus 80 freezers at this stage so
we have a lot of samples and we would
like to use them
we had previously run two requests for
proposals on an annual basis
for for academics to access the samples
we decided that wasn't sufficient so
that that now runs
year round i've given the website
address there for anyone who wants to
inquire
we do have a tier system so if you look
on the right
in tier 1 for example would be the most
valuable sample would be a serum sample
from a dog prior to its cancer diagnosis
and the least valuable sample would be
hair or toenails
from a dog without any of the diseases
of interest
that said any day a dog could move from
tier 4 to tier 1
so it's definitely a changing picture as
we move
through the study here are some of the
studies the first four
occurred through those first annual
requests for proposals
with topics ranging from heart disease
through obesity
to training veterinary scientists to the
gut microbiome
the study at the bottom blood profiling
for early detection of lymphoma
just came through our open call so we're
just starting that study now
the other resource we have is our data
commons so we have
quite a bit of the phenotypic data
available out there this can include
a medical diagnoses behavior all sorts
of demographics
this is currently available to academics
and i've given the website
by which you can inquire we do ask for
identification
with both the samples and the data we're
very happy to talk to private sector
partners so again if you just contact
us directly and we can talk about what
you would like to do
another very exciting thing that has
happened
late last year is that the v foundation
with their strong interest in
comparative oncology
humans versus dogs arranged a matching
fund
for us so a generous donor gave a
million
they matched it at one of their events
with another million
and so currently we are genotyping all
of the dogs
uh this is using a snip chip array and
that data will ultimately be available
for researchers to use obviously this is
huge value when it is associated with
all of the phenotypic information that
we have collected
later on this year we're going to start
deep sequencing of the genomes from
cancer dogs
both their normal tissue and the cancer
tissues themselves
so we'll really be getting into some
deep cancer science looking at aspects
such as mutation
i mentioned before that a dog could go
from the lowest tier of value to the
highest the middle
the minute that dog is diagnosed with
cancer
uh so we do wish to start looking at
some of our data around the cancer dogs
with the genotyping
so we decided to recruit some controls
so we initiated the golden oldies
project
where we asked people with golden
retrievers over 12 years of age who
obviously have not
yet succumbed to cancer to get us a
blood sample
for dna extraction we figure that a
golden retriever that's made it to 12
has probably basically won the game
in terms of cancer and we wanted to get
these studies started
as soon as we could we really had an
overwhelming response we were looking
for about 200 and were worried we
might only get half of that but within a
few weeks we had almost 300
people uh inquire and become eligible
to submit their samples so we're right
in the middle of that at the moment
it was a very touching to see how much
people responded to the study
and and wanted to help us and i just
wanted to share some of the wonderful
photos that they send us we do ask them
for those when they send the sample
particularly like the one on the top
left of the
dog with the snowy face running through
the snow
the photograph on the top right kelsey
is the mother of those puppies behind
her
that litter are all in the golden
retriever lifetime study
so then she was able to join them with
her golden oldie samples
and we were also surprised by how active
some of these
uh 12 year old and older goldens
actually are here but here are a couple
of them competing
or running along the beach so everyone
enjoyed uh seeing that as the samples
came in
one thing i really wanted to emphasize
is that a scientist you know we're
thinking of this as
data data points uh you know what
publications can we get out of this and
how can we advance the science
but a very very big part of the study
for us are the participants
and by participants we mean not only the
dog owners but also
the study veterinarians to whom these
dogs go every year
you may have noticed with the photos of
the dogs that we call them heroes so
they each have a hero number
and then we have our supporters which
are not only people who are interested
in helping out with the study
but also any other pets that are in the
homes where the heroes live
on facebook we have the 3 000 strong
community
they run this themselves you know we
make sure we get the right information
to them it's become a very strong
community of people
helping each other stay in the study and
just helping each other personally
in fact i was talking to one of the
volunteers and she told me that this
study is
the most important thing she's ever done
in her life which i think is very
touching that people are so committed to
a study of this type obviously we are
losing dogs to cancer and other causes
and ultimately we're going to lose them
all
so we have very solid bereavement team
support
and we make sure that we generate
memorials for the heroes as we lose them
from the study
one thing we did want to flag and this
has been arranged by
dr page as a workshop for the national
academies of science engineering and
medicine
this is very prestigious uh particularly
to get canine science being recognized
in this way
this will be in the role of companion
animals as sentinels for predicting
environmental exposure effects on both
aging
and cancer susceptibility in humans and
we do gather quite a lot of
information about the environment of
these dogs as we're going through the
study
so we'll be supporting this workshop and
we'll be attending it
which we are hoping will be sometime
next year
if covert 19 allows us to meet again
just to finish off i wanted to again
lift up some of the people involved in
the study
this is our study steering committee
comprised of scientists from all sorts
of fields
including genomics nutrition behavior
the microbiome
these people are helping us you know get
the most scientific value
out of this very long study indeed and
we appreciate them being involved
there's certainly been a lot of
generosity from the scientific community
and i'd like to finish off really by
acknowledging
our partners the founding partners were
the morris family
the mark and betty morris family
foundation
and then other partners who have helped
us both financially and scientifically
including the petco foundation who have
a great relationship with us for which
we're very grateful
uh blue buffalo vca of course the v
foundation all of us uh just been a
wonderful partner
and then our gold sponsors including the
golden retriever foundation we are of
course very involved with
people who support the golden retriever
breed and the hadley and marion stewart
foundation in addition to zoetis
and finally our golden champion mars
veterinary we wouldn't get where we were
today
without the people in the study the
scientific
community and these partners who have
helped make this happen
thank you for your attention
you